[Música]
y lo que quieren platicar con ustedes el
día de hoy es hombre
y algunos
de seguro de crédito
monterrey un negocio
y ojalá no pasaba el tiempo y no tenía
ventas no tener utilidades seguía
soltera y no más joven no más flaca y él
que algo estaba haciendo mal
y me gustaria que repitiera una
definición que es parte general de
sistemas
por favor
finalidad
lo que significa es que tú puedes llegar
a lograr lo que tú te propongas
y yo lo que quería es capitalista con
dinero
no necesariamente en las tarjetas de
crédito a costa de tu esposo del
gobierno
[Música]
y cuándo
vivía yo me cambié gracias porque está
en un trabajo que me gustaba cantar dos
veces en celular y eso no fue lo que
hago
lo peor fue
que de repente el sábado a las 7 de la
mañana pues del ministerio público
necesitamos que estén ahí
y 17 años
y entonces que tienes que reconocer el
cuerpo
[Música]
cuando no tenía el dinero de que esté
más grande que quiero cambiar radicar y
es donde a veces
y tienes que hacer valer y la razón por
la cual estás aquí
y es por eso que decidimos ultimar con
la empresa porque puedan tema legal
cuando se muere que sucio o se es todo
chao y entonces hicimos los cambios y
las modificaciones y me prometí a mi
visita aquí para transformar o que iba a
transformar mi realidad y les quiero
compartir los tics que a mí me han
funcionado sobre todo para liberarte del
pasado
y transformar inventiva nadar todos los
segundos y todos los minutos de
tensiones
porque si mañana no sabe si mañana gana
béticos es que tú estás y que puedas
vamos a verificar el tema del tiempo de
estar con tus papás del tiempo de estar
con tus hijos sobre todo porque estás
trabajando y estás generando dinero y no
es una fórmula mágica
[Música]
el primer concepto que me gustaría
platicar es la parte d
de la actividad positiva si tú siempre
te estás quejando y para una reflexión
de cuántas veces antes gratuita de hoy
aunque dejarme más entonces en nuestra
parte de la actitud positiva los invito
a que por lo menos los siguientes 30
días nos quedan 50 días para catar el
año los vinos para que en el a partir de
hoy con demostrar integrales y no
pasemos quejándonos todos los días un
día a la vez cada día por 30 días y les
aseguro que van a ver las cosas
diferentes y que aquí también
el tiempo que nos la pasamos de todo lo
que está mal entonces es de la protesta
a la propuesta que estás haciendo hoy
aquí sentado sobre todo transformando la
realidad de tu familia de tu pobreza no
seas siempre tendemos a tener más o
querer más pero que estás tuvo aciertos
para construir esa realidad
la otra parte es el enfoque normalmente
quiere pasar muchas cosas pero no las
estamos desarrollando en contra de las
personas
qué te apasiona qué harías gráficos para
entonces
y sobre todo no es que eres bueno eso
que te apasiona y cómo ganar dinero es
ahí donde se integra está esta región
donde vas a ser libre vas a disfrutar
levantarte todos los días que aprovecha
está segundo para construir lo que a ti
te gusta sobre todo que te dejen porque
porque el concepto de
en la parte de lo que estás haciendo que
no te está funcionando y sobre todo como
lo estás modificando y no es que no haya
tenido ninguna situación estresante los
últimos cinco años sino que aprender es
hasta cometer los mismos errores hasta
está con las mismas
patrones de comportamiento y lo que
tengo también como tips en el tema de
género eso si ustedes quieren ser menos
pobres o querer ser más ricos lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es gastar menos de
lo que ganamos porque todos vivimos
endeudados totalmente solamente por el
qué dirán pero no construimos
específicamente nuestra meta de vida
he perdido el 10% del salario que se ha
trabajado más de 2 millones de pesos
pero que no tenía cosas
de los 70 o los más importantes sobre
todo no transmitir la responsabilidad ni
pasar a otras generaciones la visión de
pobreza el ciclo de crisis
y siempre porque siempre tenemos la
parte de los emprendedores pero
normalmente no
llevamos una medición de avance es decir
gastar menos de lo que gana cada día hay
muchos objetos como la moneda de 10
pesos en la parte de la llana un cajón o
hay aplicaciones actualmente que se
pueden ahorrar a pesar de que las
personas
es decir que ese sector
pero requiere un esfuerzo de la mañana
así no lo vas a bajar
a los 7 años empezó a hablar tú cuántos
años tienes en comparación en la parte
del agua y la tercera realidad es
diversificar tus intereses qué pasaría
si te ocurriera acción y quién pagaría
superior yo no sabía cuántas deudas
dejarías a otras personas o sea cuánto
medio que estar tratando de hacer porque
ese proceso de negación y este es el
concepto que yo les quiero platicar que
tenemos
lo que tienes que hacer
es que cuesta dinero
el líder de fe para mañana porque tienes
que hacer si el momento como mexicanos
quisiéramos lo que tenemos que hacer y
lucy vamos a la primera hora del día
sería una gran victoria porque sí no
[Música]
se llama
las personas exitosas se come las 4 de
la mañana a las 2 horas de gimnasio este
desayuno que salía esto desde la lista
que tienes que hacer es ya sea correr a
cortar a alguien no saben tomar la
decisión de renunciar en el trabajo que
no te gusta y dejar de quejarte y
vestigios phoenix está en la parte de la
estimación
para tomar decisiones que normalmente le
queremos echar la culpa a dios al
principio tu papá
a los astros a nosotros de la decisión
la solución
y la corrupción como mencionan acciones
de dos así como en el sexo hay dos
también esta parte en la corrupción y
también en la parte de que seguimos
siendo pobres y su culpa no si no tiene
nuevo este portal no es porque ellos que
dice quién es la fecha límite 17 de
noviembre y barcelona
oigan es diagnóstico para nada yo tenía
20 días para pagar una clásico mexicana
que creo que es la propuesta de empezar
a hacer cosas pequeñas cosas no levantar
de más pobre por no contar los intereses
o por qué
[Música]
ahora
esa parte la relación que es lo que
debemos hacer que tendríamos que hacer
por los dejamos para después y conozco
personas que les están quitando tiempo
entonces es importante esta parte de
sino lo mejor es plantear y puede
cambiar sin tomar decisiones y ya tienes
más de 18 años como para poder moverte
el ataque que también les quiero
mencionar es la parte de ese recipiente
y tiene que ver con las etiquetas nos
quedemos siempre victimizados
en la parte y yo soy de todos menos para
él
de poder
y sobre todo cuidar etiquetas de mí
mismo es el peor enemigo
esperando a ver 5 con la pole y eso nos
da una fórmula mágica donde tú puedes
hacer en la parte d
me encontré cuando siempre te dicen es
que no se puede
el rector de todas las personas y tener
mi negocio
quieren comerse el mundo y no tienen con
qué
y
la oportunidad está dispuesta y tengo
que trabajar como un negro para vivir
porque estemos seleccionada y esto es el
revés hemos hecho lo que aprendí en la
parte de la estrategia es si se puede
tener un balance siglo xxi del cine
sistemático está en el esposo usted no
tiene que decidirlo con nuestra
ingeniería la mitad de las mujeres y los
primeros que contrataban en hablar los
hombres sobre todo por el seno de usted
va se embaraza y entonces te vas a casar
con alguien y ya vamos a poder trabajar
entonces también él lo que yo lo místico
de instituto se puede él a nuestra
medida que quiere es el control el
enfoque y la actitud positiva e intenta
se intente 70's tiene que
fracasé en tres o cinco empresas para
encontrar el modelo que si no tienes que
acostumbrarte al fracaso el fracaso como
entidad tendrá
no sé
dónde
vas pasando los años y vas disfrutando
como los vinos añejos estos momentos
donde si no estás en el celular tampoco
pasa nada si no estabas esté publicando
en facebook no pasa nada es lo que es
que pasa es que tú decidas la realidad
que tú quieres y es por eso que la frase
del que me gusta y en este resumen que
yo quiero compartirles es hay que ser
parte de la solución y no del problema
lo que tienes es para ti y permite que
por encima de ti
y entonces
la subida es más complicado
nosotros nos dedicamos al arte hemos
apoyado algunos proyectos hay nuevas
fórmulas a comparación de hace 15 años
hay nuevas formas opciones psicológico
que les generan dinero sin dinero
condición tampoco lo vas a hacer todo es
parte de la idea porque hay muchos y una
gran idea aún así las personas que han
transformado la realidad en este punto
yo les dejaría ir
para viviendo los pocos niveles hay que
hacer lo que pocos están dispuestos
dispuestos a hacer tú que estás
dispuesto a hacer para dejar de ser
seguir siendo pobre muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]